what was it about your world perspective
that Charlie challenged
you know I say in the book that as
young people we are complexifiers
uh we we take this simple world of
childhood and we discover all the
complexity to it and the world is not as
easy or as just or as uh uh kind as we
thought or were told
if you live long enough
certainly in Charlie's case what you do
is you realize that yeah the world's
complicated but what you do about it is
pretty simple
you practice kindness uh practice
generosity spread Joy all these simple
things Charlie helped remind me the
reason they're so familiar because
they're true this is what works